comfortable with the idea of I know the
water's not nice yeah I'm not here like
if I get pregnant I haven't I'm like do
you know what if I like you don't get in
a car thinking I'm gonna be in a car
accident but you know full well every
time you get in a car or you get on a
plane yeah like there is a low-key
chance that this could not end well for
me it's just interesting because
whenever like I talk to people about it
and they always
um
make it seem like it's only using like
chill but not not no that's not chill
that it's only used in cases of
emergencies and like like all that stuff
but and my feeling is that it's more
used as a form of birth control today
rather than and it's usually because
there's some form of irresponsibility so
rather than like the exceptions so that
is very so I was a sexual health advisor
for the largest trust in the UK be
Pastor the British pregnancy advisory
service
every single person that I know that's
had it was like just them being
irresponsible like it was literally just
them being like I don't know a single
person well I I've in my time in my
position I'd only spoken to one girl who
was like oh yeah I need an abortion but
I used to know the B pass number but off
by heart it's something like oh 300 300
800 or 0300 800 oh I mean I do it off by
heart but the first woman I ever spoke
to and assisted in abortion she was a
married woman she had two kids her
oldest son was um disabled
um she was like even my daughter that we
had was like an accident but a happy
accident and she was like she was
sobbing to me on the phone she was like
in her late 30s and she was like
something maybe say that's not really
like natural if we're like sobbing like
like if that's your reaction to it yeah
yeah no no not at all but then I was
like you don't need to explain yourself
to me I was like it's not my business I
was like it's not my business it's not
my opinion I was like you like you've
clearly had like a nice night with your
husband your family like you've got a
lot of [ __ ] going on I was like it's not
my business
yeah but then I've also spoken to
some women who were like really chill
like hey I need them as if it's birth
control yeah and they're like
honey like that's just just go just go
on proper birth control you know you
know my mom was in a position where she
like she like most people would have
advised her to get an attention because
she was 17 and she got pregnant but um
by my dad actually at the time and they
actually ended up like giving up that
kid for adoption and he like
he ended up being like a really
successful like sales software engineer
he just got married that's why I
actually have a really hard time with it
because I feel like if anyone was gonna
get it it could have been my mom like
she was broke she was 17. so this is
very interesting yeah um I studied under
Professor Roger Ingram if he's ever
watching which he might want to be so I
studied
um psychology of sex health and we did
um my personal project was outcomes of
teenage conception yeah and it's proven
all of the research and you have to
obviously look in the bias all the
research shows that it's more harmful
for the woman the bearer of that child
to have a child and give it up than it
is to have an uh what does that mean
it's more like so the woman for the rest
of her life will be like did I make the
right choice is my child okay rather
than being like I'm gonna have and this
is why and so I think I think a lot of
times like again we're making it about
us when it's really it's not about you
because there's a kid in the picture
yeah so
why is that kid more important than you
wow I mean I think in my mom's case like
he grew up to like have a really great
life yeah yeah like and so it kind of
like rubs me the wrong way I think I
think that's like why it rubs me wrong
way a little bit when people are like
make it not a life because like my
brother grew up and like yeah did all
these like amazing yeah and that's
always going to make but this is why so
uh we're drinking groom he's a pro he's
a professor he's like the best in his
field
um he so he literally told everyone he
was like we don't use the term pro-life
right to be pro-life you would have to
be a vegetarian a vegan you won't step
on an amp but you would care about that
woman yeah telling you I want an
abortion
well then you're not pro-life because
that's a life that's that's not a human
life so then your pro-human life but
then if you're pro-human like I think
it's like easily implied like like
everyone everyone you know okay okay let
me just let me just let me just ask you
do you think there's a difference
between a human life and an ant yeah I
do but then it's still a life it's like
but I know but like is you're just kind
of trying to get like a gotcha question
like oh it's a little one clearly
everyone knows the woman is yeah
why is her life less important because I
don't think just because you have a kid
your life is over I also think I also
think the argument is that she's in that
situation because of the decisions that
she's made
whereas the consequences happening to
the child which is the only innocent
party arguably does that make sense but
again it's like if it's a ball of cells
but also okay what if she's on
contraception
like it has a unique DNA sequence yeah
like are you very like you can see
if she doesn't value it why is it
valuable to everyone else and then we go
on to adoption okay if these kids are
valuable why are we overrun in every
Western community of like children get
that's it they get so you think the kids
aren't valuable if they're poor I think
they're valuable but definitely not
being adopted by people who are pro-life
they're they are they are my parents are
pro-life they adopted three kids and
yeah but that's but that's just your
personal experience right there's a lot
of people that want to adopt like even
now like yeah
could you let me finish um I'm sorry but
the problem is that like the legal
systems are aren't don't make it easy
yeah no no so a lot like there's
families that have been waiting for
years to adopt but like they want a baby
they don't want a kid that's been
waiting for years oh for sure that's I
mean I've seen like I've actually seen
the negative like consequences of
getting a kid that's too old it's really
hard to do like if you if you get them
past a certain age a lot of them come
with a lot of issues yeah like this is
it yeah
so I think ideally I think ideally like
it would be better if the kids were
adopted earlier rather than like growing
up in foster care like that's not good
for any kids yeah but then they don't
get a choice in that they don't get to
say when they're born that's just a
decision made for them by being forced
to be born and there's a lot of people
who will joke and be like I didn't ask
me born so I was suicidal for three
years and I was like I didn't ask people
and my mom will say to me my mom is
my mom will say to me I wish she's like
I wish I could do yeah that's really sad
that's really yeah but I know she
doesn't mean it I know she loves me but
she's like I have so much guilt and she
was a mum who carried us the term who
looked after us and she's like I still
feel like I can't provide for you and
I'm like no I get it I understand that
you would not have a lot of guilt you
wouldn't have a lot of like
responsibility like xyzad
um but again it's like it's also a
difference I understand that for a lot
of people they're successful at stories
for a lot of people
um but for myself individually yeah it's
just very I'm very pro-choice yeah right
it's not black it's just like almost
like we focus on like the negative
stories rather than the positive like
even even when me and you talking about
this now like your focus immediately is
well there's all these kids in foster
care that can't get adopted rather than
like the story I just told you of the
three adult like right you know it's
just weird how like that that's your
immediate Focus rather like there's both
you know what I mean I I have I have a
question just played Devil's Advocate um
do you do you think there's any
circumstance where it is better for a
human being not to be born
than to have a life no matter how much
suffering there is in it
that's really like let's talk about
Ukraine right now like oh I'll give you
I'm giving him a better I'll give you
I'll give you a better example let's
talk about slavery
would you say it was better for a child
slave to not be born than to be born and
go through slavery but then potentially
have the chance for Freedom depending
that's really hard that's uh it's very
subjective it's very like
because there are some people who go
through [ __ ] and they're like
um so statistically and anthropology
like anthropology
the highest quality of life is seen in
less economically developed countries so
people in like uh Nigeria and Ethiopia
are actually happier than those of us in
Western societies and they've got much
less and it's because you know the
little things mean more to them so it's
like we look at them as quote-unquote
Charity they have more meaning in their
lives we look at them it's like
quote-unquote charity cases and a lot of
westernized people are like oh Africa is
poor Africa's Exposition it's like but
actually they're very happy they're very
happy with a lot less than what we are
and it's very subjective it's very like
I do not have the
um
I do not have the power to determine
what makes a good life to anyone but
myself but I'm just I'm just asking a
question I'm gonna ask you as well like
do you is there any is there any
circumstance where you believe that a
life being unborn is better than the
life not being born
so
big thing I love
um yes or no
um I I don't I say I don't have a black
or white yes or no but a big thing a big
fact is so in I believe it's Sweden 100
of embryos screened for Down syndrome
are aborted 100 because they believe an
individual with Down Syndrome
won't have a good quality of life and I
fully disagree I work a lot with people
with developmental disabilities and so
people are like oh so if you've got and
um I interviewed Cambridge and they said
this is the evidence that if you have if
you're pregnant and you live in a uh
built up area and uh carbon emissions it
means you're more likely to have a child
with autism and they said okay discuss
this with me and I went I'm not going to
discuss it and they were like okay why
and I said okay so you're telling me if
I live here you want me to argue about
whether or not my child is more or less
likely to have autism and I always went
it doesn't matter to me and they're like
why and I was like because if my child
has autism I don't care I was like I
will love my child regardless of how
it's born yeah yeah
I just don't understand how you can't
answer that question because nothing's
black or white yes or no like you can
either think of an example or you can't
I can think of an example for pro and an
example for con no as in like can you is
there any example where you can think of
that a life has so much suffering it was
better that life was never born in the
first place
I think that but then I think the
opposite so
then so I would then I'd say so the
answer to your question then to the
answer to the question originally is
yes as in you do believe that a life it
is better you do believe there's a
situation where it is better for a life
not to be born if it's life was to
entail so much suffering
but then that is dependent upon my own
bias and my own you're asking for your
opinion yeah yeah ah like that you say
slavery obviously you'd be like I
wouldn't want anyone to go through
slavery but then there are people who go
through slavery who could be like well
actually
this is my reality do you ever XYZ is
good about my life
in spite of slavery I've got a good
quality of life like it's so who am I to
tell you that your life isn't good like
oh no we're just just asking for like
okay yeah so now it's all it is is all
it is is that as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible